there's a story on blm i want to take
from a slightly different angle
than we usually do this is a radio host
who
is a radio host in new york
she had gone on the air one day probably
many days and said
f the police set the police typical sort
of thing you would hear from
blm or from the radical left and then
hours later
she kills a police officer in her car
take a listen
i will see you guys next monday at 6
30 p.m
back here and face reality radio on the
instagram and on the
facebook and until then
the police until then
that's like her sign off right and then
hours later this 32 year old woman
jessica beauvais
hit a police officer a highway officer
in her volkswagen
he was redirecting traffic and she
killed him why did she kill him did she
target him because he was a cop no i
don't think there's evidence of that
but she was hammered she was drunk and
high in the studio she drank a lot she
admitted to this
to drinking a bunch to smoking a bunch
of pot and
then totally impaired she kills this guy
she killed anastasio sacco's 43 father
of a six-year-old daughter and a
three-year-old son
he was redirecting traffic after a
separate fatal car accident
and she hit and killed him and you know
what her reaction was this direct quote
why did my first accident have to be a
cop not that i wanted it to be someone
else
but f i've been driving since i was 16
and haven't hit as much as a pothole
fairly callous and selfish response
but put all that aside for a sec she was
probably still drunk and high at the
time
i i don't see any evidence that this
woman was aiming at a cop i mean she's
saying gosh why did i why did i do this
it's going to ruin her life
the reason i bring it up is not to say
this is a terrible woman i mean she did
terrible things
if you get super drunk and high and then
get behind the wheel you are endangering
people
but i i mentioned it to bring up what
she said on the show f the police
that's probably the last thing that
people are going to remember probably
the first thing and the last thing
people are going to remember about this
woman
and i wonder if she's got any conscience
in her whatsoever
how that's going to go through her head
she's
going to remember that she killed this
guy father of young kids
because of her irresponsibility and the
last thing that she said was f the
police
not good stuff guys not good stuff
you do not want to have these sorts of
regrets from a purely selfish standpoint
even
you do not want to live with this kind
of stuff on your conscience whether it's
acting responsibly and then hurting
somebody or whether it's even just
saying a cruel vicious thing and then
god forbid you know somebody dies
someone goes away and that's the last
thing that you're going to remember you
don't
want to live like that okay i joke about
it sometimes when i get
fan mail from the radical left get a
fair bit of it
i got one yesterday on instagram from
some gal and it was this
sort of vile stream of insults and
really mean things
and i responded and i said uh i don't
respond too many messages but i did see
it it popped up and i said
imagine saying this to a perfect
stranger imagine what it takes to go and
perfect strange and you go and you write
these vile things
and she had a good response she said i
don't need to imagine it
i said that was a softball you know but
touche touches a funny answer
but the reason that i respond to kind of
i just laugh these things off
is because i don't i don't want the last
thing
[Music]
that i've said to somebody to be
something vile
not even just for them not even just
because it's you know that's the wrong
thing to do
that's going to be on my conscience that
will sully me that will degrade me so i
don't want to do it
we do these things sometimes you lose
your temper whatever you know it gets
the best of you
but one wants to avoid it not not just
for the moral order but because
it's uh it's in your own interest too
you need to fight back against these
sorts of radicals you can fight back
without degrading yourself hey if we're
still on youtube i am
absolutely shocked because we really
broke the narrative today because the
studies broke the narrative if you want
those sorts of facts that you're not
going to hear from the left-wing sources
subscribe ring that bell like it and
head on over to apple podcast spotify
google play stitcher
myspace live journals and guidance we're
on all the platforms subscribe to the
michael knowles show please leave a five
star review we really appreciate that
helps us break through the walls of
censorship and suppression and get right
to you we'll see you next time
[Music]
you